Winning a football match is about more than bringing together 11 gifted players.
It's about team spirit and good tactics.
The 4-3-3 formation is made up of four defenders, three midfielders and three forwards.
Two wingers play high up the pitch to prevent counterattacks...
...and the central striker harries the opposition's central defense.
In the well-known but now lesser-used 4-4-2 or "flat four" system,...
...midfielders operate in the corridors...
...when they get possession to pass the ball on to the two forwards.
It can also be played in a diamond formation...
...with one midfielder in front of the defense and another supporting the forwards.
World-class playmakers like Pelé, Maradona and Zidane express themselves best...
...in the flexible 4-2-3-1 system,...
...setting up attacks from the middle of the line of three.
Teams that opt for the 4-1-4-1 formation are more defensive.
The aim is to neutralize the game and creativity of the opposition...
...while launching counterattacks.
This system depends upon defensive rigor and tactical discipline.
It proved a winning formula for the Greeks in their surprise Euro 2004 victory.